okay to people joining this
live stream this is a working meeting
doing incremental language development
for wolverine language
and we have a variety of topics today
the first one looks
incredibly detailed but let's see what
it is
looks scarily detailed it is specific to
something that happens once a year for
one hour
but it's a little tricky um
and so we think we have a solution for
it but we want you know i've been
meaning every
twice a year every year various clocks
that i have
which aren't fully internet connected
drive me crazy and i say
by next year i won't have to deal with
these anymore
and that's been happening for at least
20 years but okay let's see what this is
okay there are two 1 30 a.m instance on
a given time zone
time oh boy
right and so this is an ambiguity caused
by
using uh name time zones so
you know this says america chicago it's
what we think of as central time in
general
but when we just use numeric time zones
when we have daylight savings it just
switches from -6 to -5
but on a wall clock when we're observing
the time zone
for central time you have your first 130
and then when you hit 2 o'clock you fall
back to one o'clock again you have a
second 130
and so for local time when we're
in that time zone we need a way to
distinguish between
which 130 you're talking about okay so
hold on a second so
you say if i say now
do i get something which is an absolute
time zone or do i get something in a
name time zone
so right now our default for dollar time
zone is still
an absolute numeric offset um so you
have dollar time zone and we have
dollar time zone entity so at 2 am or
whatever it is
it will switch dollar i see we have a
dollar time zone entity
i see okay
so this is not a problem right now
because we use numeric time zones by
default but if users
want to use timezone ids then there is
an ambiguity
and that's what we want to solve
okay i understand so the user types in
this thing
with the timezone entity of america
chicago
and the problem is that there are two of
those right
and we need some way to distinguish them
and so we have sort of a two-fold
proposal one of them
is that we have this leap variant
element that we've been using
uh since 12-2 for the new calendars that
have leap months and leap days
they get interwoven yeah i think this is
the same thing it's a leap hour
right it's a leap hour and so to partly
make that
a little more clear we're also proposing
adding a second argument that's
effectively like a label or a descriptor
of what that leap variant refers to
um why not do that in other cases as
well i mean like i think that's what
we'd do yeah is we'd basically extend it
for the cases where it's a leap month we
could say
you know it's a lunar leap month
right but perhaps and canonicalized to
that
canonicalism through argument form i
i think so yeah because it's it's not
ambiguous in any cases
okay go ahead what you're going to say i
was thinking whether
to have the default case being calendar
related
and i mean what we have right now
doesn't have the second argument
because it's driven by the calendar
which
it could be the default because i mean
if we want to
to have it a second argument for
calendars what could we write there
some calendars are going to be solar
there may be some other reason
so we would write calendar library and
comma calendar
no that doesn't make any sense i mean
like leap variant
okay
what happens if you type in february
30th
so right now what we have in in date
list and everything else is that we
have a normalizer that says if you
provide a date that is out of bounds it
will basically add it on to the end
so if you said february 30th of 2021
it would give you march 2nd since
there's no 29th
yeah okay um
okay does leap variant what's what's the
most
everyday use of leap variant currently
the most common instance of it
is for a leap month in a lunar solar
calendar
okay and so what what does it look like
it's just like
leap variant 11 or something go ahead
yeah
leap variant of the month number in the
month position
there are some calendars that also have
leap days
but there's only one leap variant for
any given calendar is that true
no there are calendars with library and
simultaneously in months and days
i understand but there aren't multiple
yeah the leap variant doesn't move
different directions if it's a
leap month it falls after
[Music]
the unnamed or the undecorated leap
version
i see so so i see what you're saying so
this
is so it's month
11 the are there other can there be more
than one leap variant at month 11
that is you can have a first you know
month 11
and then a then a 11 a and 11 b or only
in 11a
only in 11a in any calendar that i've
seen i'm not
aware of any even that we've looked at
in passing
that have multiple leap variants for a
single instance
right i agree with that yeah and we
don't have ever
two reasons to change a month in the
same calendar okay so here
this is doubling the 1am is that correct
what happens when you're doing the other
way round so
the other way around we basically have
an hour that doesn't exist
so in a couple lines above that we have
time zone offset is a place we're
thinking about making it at least
possible for
users to do local time lookups so i can
provide a date and say what are the time
zone offsets at this local time
and it's either one offset two offsets
or no offset
and so what we basically figured we'd do
is if you provide a time that doesn't
exist
we would give a warning and then we
could basically normalize to an hour
later
fine but the case of difficulty is one
there's
you know not when you lose an hour but
when you gain an hour and when
okay right our 25-hour long day is the
one that is particularly thorny because
we don't have a good way to disambiguate
right now we just default to
if you say 1am we assume you mean the
second 1am and there's not an easy way
you mean the most
the the 1am that is about to be 1am
yes the one after the transition
i think this is reasonable then to do
leap variant and leap variant means
after the transition and the unleap
varianted
means before the transition is that what
you had in mind yeah that's what i had
in mind
and then at the convenience we basically
figured you know it's possible
someone might want to specify leap
variant on the time zone itself at that
moment and we could basically just
canonicalize to the normal form of
moving the leap variant onto the hour
because in in some regards people
consider
the keeping track of the shift in
transition
is part of the hour and some standards
sort of look at it as part of the
time zone i don't think it would be a
common input but it's something that
wouldn't be ambiguous
yeah okay all right well so i mean
that use of the time zone with librarian
just is very weird
but i mean i guess it's okay it's a very
corner case
yeah just something for input
fair enough okay so this question about
the second argument's elite variant
right now if we introduce this we
basically have three different cases
where elite variant comes up it's either
a leap
month primarily due to a luna solar
calendar
a leap day for basically the same reason
or
this daylight saving transition
for an hour and so
for the first two cases we could just
say you know
it's leap variant number comma lunasolar
or we could say it is leap variant of
leap month or leap day
i i like being a little more specific
than just saying it's calendar related
oh yeah i agree but i mean you know it's
in the uh
you know a day because it's sitting in
the day position
yeah right um hmm
i mean look the more obvious thing
would be that it's sort of the reason
it's like a it's like a failure thing
it's a reason as in leap year like leap
variant
of well wait a minute
you're saying the simplest case is it's
a leap month
yeah so so in a sense the second
argument is an explanatory
thing that says this is in here because
it's elite month
right right to me it was
a warning that this is not calendar
related like the other
leap variants to me leap
is most the first thing that comes to
mind is calendar related
but this is not calendar driven these
these additional months are they
actually called leap months in the local
cultures or are they called something
different
they always have specific names i mean i
think in
in india they had this adika word they
repeated things always called adhika
which i think we asked sushma and she
said it was effectively like
leap
okay but does it mean leap or does it
mean something completely different like
addended or something
i mean i don't know why they're called
leap i mean
leap as in jump i have no idea why
they're called leap
do you know why they're called leap no
not off hand for example in spanish what
are they called are they called
something with a similar
kind of meaning or something completely
different
no uh in spanish it's called b siesta
which has a funny story it comes from
latin
and the original word the the original
thing that
the romans did is to repeat the day
number six
and so these sixtus became b siesta
it means the second sixth
this is a mess guys it it is in spanish
we say
uh it's like like
this sixth day or bis even though we're
talking about the 29th of february is
that right
exactly yes it's it's because the the
romans were repeating the
sixth day before calendars before the
the beginning of the next month i see
and it looks like the
at least from the the quick search i did
for leap the reason we
call it a leap year is actually because
normally year over year
we progress one day during the week
so february 1st will be a monday and the
next day
year it'll be a tuesday then a wednesday
but during leap years it skips an extra
element
oh my goodness language is silly
particularly when it comes to dates
but i wonder if the name leap variant is
actually right
although we should call it something
different call it something like
um we also have the presence of lip
seconds
which which we we are planning to use
also the same
idea i understand in the second place
and that's called lip second
i understand but that's called leap
seconds because by the time they were
being named
everybody was used to the idea of leap
years even though nobody could remember
where they came from
right correctly yes there
um
my point is that the terminology leap
month or leap day
and libya is using in calendrical
computations
and leap second so i think leap is the
right name
our is the thing that we haven't seen
but seems like
like the natural it's a natural thing if
it's a leap second it's a leap
hour exactly i i would say okay by the
way sandra on the
livestream is pointing out why do we not
have an america chicago
summer and slash winter as a
specification of the time zone
we could do that i mean that's sort of
there there's two
different approaches to it either we
want to have time zones that are
fully specified out and say this is the
time zone
and this is the daylight time
observation mode but it does sort of
break the
connection we have with the entity world
so like the notion is that
america chicago is a time zone entity it
has its own transition rules it has its
own history it has its own properties
and a summer time and a wintertime
version of that
are just different phases of that entity
if that makes sense but we have entity
variant we have the notion of an entity
variant
yeah that's true we could potentially
look at it you know the other option is
instead of having america chicago
summer we could have america chicago gmt
minus
six which i forget the technical name
for that jose but there's a there's a
time but
i'm saying we could use the entity
variant wrapper
rather than having rather than using a
leap variant wrapper
look okay so look i i'm i'm sold on the
leap variant as the way of dealing with
this
crazy extra hour i think the second
argument is probably going to get us
it's not convincing to me who's just
going to say
you know i think we should this is a
really corner case if somebody sees this
they kind of look at the documentation
for leap variant and they'll know what's
going on
and they'll say oh my gosh i wonder how
long it took those guys to figure out
this was the thing to do
yeah the um it's true that we
so far we only have one reason to move
hours so
there is no no true need to disambiguate
it right you could just have the
body and want right i think that's what
we should do in terms of this time zone
leap variant thing
um i mean are you imagining what happens
if you want different treatments of the
leap seconds
things like that i mean there's there's
a lot of diversity in what you could
want in the time zone isn't there
different treatment yeah i mean
leap second handling tends to be more
located on the time system than the time
zone
but we probably it is true we probably
don't want to have
leap variant showing up in potentially
four or five different places in a data
object
by the way where are we going to put
other planets
time systems people are going to start
caring you know like this year there's
enough mars probes going off
that people might start caring about
that
eventually i mean even each spacecraft
has
its own time system at some time
yes nasa has special files for time for
each spacecraft
and so wait a minute i mean it's like t
plus
blah blah blah hours i mean based on
launch time or what
some of them for example there is even a
gps time which is
atomic time displaced by a number of
seconds and then they count it in weeks
and seconds
and things like that so there are
specific things for
for spacecrafts and and i do have some
information about that but
it's not in the first round of no astro
things to worry about
no okay we will
get there so i'm not convinced about
this i think this is a complicated mess
i think we should deal with this to deal
with this corner case and not worry
about this right now
okay okay okay all right
good all right is this as horrifying as
that one or is this simpler
this is a follow-up on a discussion we
had a few weeks ago um
and we have michael here also but he
jose eric and i have all been talking
about
now i really want this i really want
this this is the wolf now for like
behavior
i've just put it in some reasonable unit
system right
and so our proposal for that is that
we're making some tweaks to how
uniconvert
si works so that it will allow us to
rescale
si units the current version says
we look at things like meters meters
have unbounded
normal range so if you put in meters it
doesn't matter how big or small it is it
stays as meters
let me understand something do we have a
one-argument form of unit converts
we do it changes to si base units
um which i think is that i think
yes and everything because it makes
absolutely canonical right
and it's used in tons of places we
shouldn't change that no okay fine
i'm not sold on the conventional units
story
yeah we don't love the name for it but
the idea sort of being
that you know for there are at least
commonly occurring units of length for
different scales
so we know that you know it would be
more useful potentially to come back in
light years
or um a you
instead of yoda meters necessarily
yeah yeah yeah right but okay so the
real question is
um
i mean to me this is a really pretty
common well
it depends at the wall from alpha level
this is obviously a an absolutely
standard thing to want to do at the
level
of well from language it's less
obviously less obviously common
yeah there are cases where it's
relatively common so
dealing with lengths of time potentially
dealing with file sizes
those are instances where we kind of
have a set
number of units that get used frequently
and it's nice to basically say
well so yeah i mean as sander points out
on a live stream
uh you know automatic is a perfectly
reasonable possible second argument for
unit convert
we thought of that but we don't really
love the dissonance between
automatic as a second argument yeah you
know where
i'm going with that but yeah i had
thought of the same thing again and
jose had convinced me that it's
a little incongruous to have automatic
give a different
result than just the one argument form
so to me the second discussion is that
with very very large
numbers it's very difficult to
understand what a gigameter is
while we all have a good understanding
of our light year
but because light year is not an si unit
we cannot return
light years in the comma is i
no no i understand or may have six for
example
no no i mean i think the functionality
is clear but by the way there's another
piece of functionality question
which is when do you return you know
kilogram meters per second squared and
when you
return you know uh whatever that is um
jewels or whatever when
when do you convert when does unit
convert
combine things into you know
pascals versus you know force per unit
area type stuff
i think this is a discussion of unit
convert versus unit simplify
okay so is unit simplify doing
the traditional thing
so to speak of is this trying to do the
what i mean if i gave here
kilowatt hours would it turn that into
joules or would it leave it as kilowatt
hours
would try and turn it into joules um
i mean the main issue right now with
unit simplify versus
unit convert is that unit simplify at
least in its current form
isn't concerned with the numeric value
of the quantity
it's strictly trying to condense the
unit part
and so it doesn't you know if you give a
hundred million
right although unit simplify could do
this other conventional units thing as
well
it's good good
so at the moment it's only looking at
the complexity of the unit
right i don't see why it shouldn't do
this i mean it seems useful
and that way the only problem is that i
can see people it being kind of a scary
thing that if you well
look if it's some base thing like
gigabytes or something
bites and you say units simplify
it's not an unreasonable thing for it to
turn you know
two billion bytes into uh you know two
gigabytes
right and it does potentially
so one of the other hitches with the
conventional units we're running into is
that
we don't want it to start spitting back
imperial units for
users in europe or asia but there are
conventional units that get used for
volume or
force in imperial and it doesn't make
sense to have unit system
as an option in unit convert because
most of its operations
don't need to account for a unit system
but unit simplify could well have
a unit system option and
could do this sort of rescaling based on
the numeric factors
right sandra is raising a good point
what happens if you feed unit convert a
list of quantities
and ask for conventional units they
definitely shouldn't all wind up in the
same units
right
i mean clearly clearly that's you know
if those quantities had different
dimensions you know once a force one's
an area or something
they wouldn't end up in the same units
either so i don't think that's a hugely
problematic thing
right there's common units which does
something sort of similar in that it
tries to gather
all units of
the same dimension into the best fitting
unit value for
that scale and it so what does that
common units
it's not the most frequently used
function but it's kind of a sister
function
to unit simplifying unit convert
why isn't it even mentioned here i
it should be i will fix that
what the heck is this doing how is it
deciding what units to
land these in so it's looking at the
input list and trying to
use a basic heuristic to say okay what
is the unit
system that's most frequently occurring
and then what unit best fits the
scale within that system so in the first
case we've got two
imperial units and an si unit and
basis so this is look by the way this
should definitely refer to unit simplify
but but this to me this is like the
multi
you know this is the thing if something
is a micron and a light
year if the two successive things are
microns and light years
what is it going to do let's try um
uh let's say light years
okay because it was lost or what
if i if i do this for um
this is probably because the range that
boot force on
feet and inches is too large
so once you get into this i didn't
notice it it
it defeated itself so to speak
yeah so the numbers are so large that
it's difficult to understand them in
other units
in units other than meters so i think
this is correct
is it correct that those are rational
yeah i guess they have to be rational
numbers
yeah i see so i mean but if i say
furlongs here
okay what if i say miles
okay well this wasn't unreasonable i
agree that this would be absolutely
stupid
if this was in feet right
well that's good work on common units
part but then i think so the idea would
be
common units will do the unit simplify
type thing
anyway
yeah i think unit simplifies should
should go ahead and try and
turn it into
and that's is michael here can is some
he might have an opinion about this yes
okay do you disagree with that i mean of
making units simplify
go ahead and um put it in
you know the reasonable denomination of
those units so to speak
i think there's nothing conceptually
wrong typically the
simplify functions are a little bit of a
bigger hammer
so if one has a convert i would assume
a better complexity if you do this at
scale
well but then let's just you know
uh you know over the last there's no
philosophical disagreement
okay well fine then that's what i think
we should do and now in terms of whether
unit convert
has a name for this case which it could
have
um because you might want pure unit
conversion without changing
the dimensions
um well that's always going to happen
so i didn't mean without changing i
meant trait without changing
whether it's in force per unit area
or you know force per area or or
pressure units
right right yeah i think i think the
important thing is
is to allow yourself to go out of si
and return things like light years mega
paxters or even
earth masses something that gives you a
good idea
of what this is this is yes
is it conventional unit is that i mean
and by the way
if we have if the other options here are
things like imperial
maybe it should be conventional rather
than units right because
imperial unit systems s.i
imperial metric or conventional seems
reasonable to me
yeah i think eric had pointed out that
difference
right now i assume that conventional
traditional conventional conventional is
probably better than traditional
all right i think having the additional
unit system of conventional seems right
to me
okay excellent
okay anything else for this item
and then unit simplify would do that by
default
it would use conventional by default and
unit convert
would use it if you ask for it yup makes
sense to me
okay and and the first idea on the left
the idea that s i
allows changing the prefix even if the
original thing is already in the sign
is that okay why we shouldn't i don't
see a problem with that unless michael
sees a problem with that
no we have as i base if you really want
it yes that's what i
agree okay perfect
okay all right and um with them
yeah when do we get to talk about
temperature units and logarithmic units
and so on
um yeah we should do it we have been
having
intermittent discussions about it it's
very difficult topic
but yeah there are some decisions to
make there yeah we have some prototypes
but nothing
it's quite ready to to go into detailed
design discussion around
okay and how many more horrifying things
are there there i mean
is is logarithmic the only issue and
temperature scales or other like square
root defined units things like that
i think there are two other topics that
are
uh difficult angles and content units
i think those are the four discussions
but would you agree michael yeah
but i feel like the counting one is much
more
there isn't really anything deep it's
more a matter of treatment
this is interesting
that's fun and useful
okay it'll presumably come up eventually
in the review of um
uh function repository functions
um
by the way nick is pointing out that a
reason why we were discussing ambiguity
of leap things is because apparently the
2nd 24th of february was the original
roman leap year
who knew
yeah maybe we should make sure for next
year
we can celebrate this particular feature
once it's in the system
on this day yeah we can do a november
blog post about it
we finally have a 25-hour day that works
fine
right has this come up in actual bug
reports
the 25-hour day we've gotten
external reports of it a couple of times
yeah it recently was mentioned in
mathematical stock exchange
and highly upvoted okay okay okay
well fair enough okay all right is that
that it for unit convert
i think so so michael i think that we
don't need you okay thanks
okay let's go swing from the trees here
thank you all right
how are we doing on trees do i need to
run this in a new version in a prototype
build
uh i don't think so so we have an
important question i mean
we are doing well there are many details
to worry about but there is
one particular one here that we would
like to discuss with you which is when
we map do we map by default on data or
on trees
okay you know what there was another
trees instance that just came up
who was i talking to
oh gosh what group was dealing with
something that
involved trees oh yeah yeah the people
dealing with the virtual machine
effort that involves representing this
is a
totally weird thing representing
symbolic representation of assembly code
is another thing i i pointed them at you
and and the chris cooley project for
abstract syntax
trees okay never mind that's um
um yeah we are right now contacting
various developers
in particular brenton on various
projects that
we'll use three eventually okay
all right so the question is when you
map over a tree
what does the map do does the map
well what does it do on an association
it maps on the values of an association
it does not
map does not deal with the
infrastructure of the object
it only deals with the the um
i mean this is like a map all of an
expression because it's going down
okay i see so the question is is it like
map or map all
map all well actually even that's not
right it's map minus one
not really my pole it would be more like
map and key value map
the fact that it eats the rule rather
than the
the value i would say
okay so so here we can
think of also of mapping on the
expressions or on their heads only
at a given level let me understand what
the actual options are here so
tree map so we're talking about not map
but tree map
correct correct
does map do on a tree
it's not supported
maybe it's really no reason to treat it
as
differently from mapping on lists i
don't think
i'm touching it
[Music]
it's a good point because tree is going
to be atomic
so we could use map just to map on the
data
what does map do on a graph
i don't think it works maybe it should
well the thing is what would it do so if
map
assume that map has no has no hidden
state
um then what it will do is it represents
a mapping
from one set of names
of vertices in the case of a of a of a
graph
to another set of names of vertices it's
a little bit funky i have to say
it's less funky on a tree
right because a tree is closer to an
expression right and i think
why are we treating three as atomic for
this purpose why
why not just treat it as an ordinary
expression for math
but well but it's got all kinds of stuff
inside it
right we don't want to say something
about having a special pre-map function
that can deal with that but we don't
want to serialize
trees as much as we can so
so treating them as normal expressions
would immediately have to serialize
yeah no we don't want to do that but
there's a question from
d0 on the live stream about how do you
tokenize some of the language further
the point is that assembly language in
its first form is just a string
the question is is there a symbolic
representation of it where you have op
codes and operands
and things as symbolic things that you
can then go and do pattern matching on
and so on or is it just a string
that's that's the issue um
okay in any case uh okay so look
ordinary map
seems like the obvious play is to have
it just
apply to the data
what about i mean
why okay can fold work on a tree
that was going to be the other question
because right now this problem affects
two of our functions
map trimap and three fold and we will
hoping to find a solution that would be
generalizable to future functions that
are going to be mapping things like
imagine them
a future threading function that
compares two trees to identify
differences for example
what would map index do
right exactly um because positions do
not
really need to agree in the conventions
we used
what do you mean that by
making normal functions like map or map
index working on trees
we would have to force them perhaps to
take position specs of trees
what is the possession spec of a tree
it's a list of numbers but it has the
extensions of true
relative tree level
this type of thing
but i mean there's no reason for map
index if we're feeding it something
we just won't feed it tree relative
specifications
if you say map indexed of f onto this
whole tree
why not just feed it the absolute you
know
uh branch specifications
i see that's what it should do
yeah yeah i think it will work yeah okay
so
what's less obvious to me is what fold
does because there's not an obvious
linear order on the tree
i mean there's a depth first order i
mean this is where we get into
i don't think ordinary fold makes sense
for trees right
what about accumulate
or total
well things that are defined up to a
level like total could work
how do i get a list of all the contents
of all the leaves in a tree
it would be something like 3 data of
level minus one
yeah is that is it right to make it as
comparably obscure as that
well there's also a function tree leaves
that returns the leaves
which we've which we agreed last time
are just expressions is that correct
no we agreed last time that they're
trees
is it obvious that tree leaves should
return the trees as opposed to just the
the payloads
i mean given that you can use tree data
minus one to get the
trees down there
the discussion last week was about
if we return expressions we make it
difficult to continue using them as
trees as potential things to be extended
with children
i understand that but if you ask for
tree leaves
it seems like what you're likely to want
is
okay this all this data was in a tree
but i just want the payloads
right just expression
lasting the normal expression and
removing all
structure information
say it again what it's sort of like
you're flattening
the normal of that expression i assume
they'll be the serialized
form yes and just removing all tree
structure information to get at the
nodes
yes yeah right that's what i would think
that's the right way to say it but
okay but let's go back to map okay
so i'm going to claim that map it's
pretty obvious what it should do
i'm going to claim map indexed it's also
pretty obvious what it should do
um do you do you guys agree
i think so okay all right
then okay now
you're talking about tree map why does
tree map even exist
is does tree map map onto subtrees
so hold on actually hold on hold on am i
right that
okay so what map would do was it will
look
only at payloads so if you say map at
level two
it will go to the trees at level two and
look at the
payload
wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute is it going to look at
the data or at the sub trees
so map we're saying at level two
unlike ordinary map at level two where
whatever is found at level two could
also would also contain sub-levels three
four five
etc this one would look only
at the payload data at level two
and the sub trees it would ignore is
that correct
yeah so that's why um ian wrote there
that this is like
operate because it will be looking at
the heads
the tree map is like operate because it
looks at
it looks at the head well i don't know
why you say heads i mean
it's looking at the sub trees as well as
the data tree map currently is looking
only at the data
and in that sense it's like operate
looking only at the data but we're now
saying maybe map should look only at the
data
and tree map should be the thing that
maps onto subtrees
or do we think wrong way yeah so that's
i think
one of the proposals that we're
discussing right now is that map
would take the place of the current tree
map and
the current tree map node would become
tree map
what is tree map node
that's the thing that maps on the
subtrees
that's incomprehensible as it is right
now okay so hold on a second so
why is it not more consistent now i'm
reversing myself
to have map map onto subtrees like it
does under sub-expressions
and tree map be the thing that is
mapping only onto the data
it's probably wrong the name i mean it
could be
three map map data imagine a tree map of
data
what map which what trip tree map
at data so in a sense by
by placing yourself on a part of the
expression
it seems more like a map ad it's the
same reason why i suggested that operate
should be map at head
it's more understandable what it would
do
i see what you're saying that is another
cases map at right
and you're saying mapat could work in a
tree
even with perhaps tree relative
specifications
yeah i think tree map out would also
have this same problem of do you want to
apply it to the data or the subtree
right but so if what we say is that the
tree map applies to tr
you know it returns a tree it applies
itself to a tree and it returns a tree
whereas map well does also return a tree
but it applies itself to ordinary
expressions
right in that sense is mapping
out data yes i understand
okay um
right leon on our live stream is
basically agreeing with what we're
saying here
it assumes that map would only map to
the values
yeah all right so let's let's walk
through that for a second
what other functions do we have which
are sort of related where we have this
question whether they can be supported
directly on trees
so the functions that take mapping
functions for example
um what does length do on a tree
nothing nothing yet and tree position
has its own separate thing
it's not just position right
yeah the position specs look exactly the
same that you get out
but it's that like tree extract supports
more general
kinds of position specs and we're sure
extract shouldn't be generalized to that
well we had avoided trying to use the
general functions on trees but
perhaps there is a new idea that is
appearing here
a common way of extending them right
i mean scan for example i can see being
quite useful on a tree
all right let's take a look at these
what is useful what is not useful i mean
i i don't see why this isn't useful
any true etc etc well
oh boy is it applying itself to every
node or only the leaf nodes
and and levels so at the first level
perhaps
because many of these functions by
default act on the first level yeah i
know
i know which is crazy thing which is
probably not what you want on the tree
on a tree
there are some examples to where like
the default level specs are
changed like map normally just maps
across level one by default whereas tree
map you
the default is zero to infinity
things like cases has options that don't
make sense for
or i don't know about options but like
heads doesn't make sense for trees
um wait a minute are you saying
okay the default level for map
in a tree
a pretty profoundly non-useful thing to
map only on over the level one
yep that's why the default is
zero to infinity no no no but that's for
tree map where you're mapping over whole
sub-trees
what we're talking about is as now as
map
well the alternative is we're going to
wind up with a tree map indexed et
cetera et cetera
well okay so here's a question if
could we have a single function tree map
and something about its argument
structure determines whether you are
getting
right so scroll down a little bit and
see how treefold handles this
okay but the other thing we could do i
mean we could provide
multiple arguments or maybe that's not
efficient to do
multiple arguments to the function that
is being applied
in gmap for example the data at that
level the sub tree
and even potentially the the location of
that subtree
okay what is this here tree fold
what is tree fault doing so tree fold is
doing depth first or something
it i don't think that that really
like applies what it does is it just
replaces the tree head with
a function of your choosing
recursive link consistently so you say
tree fold of f comma tree it's
as if you replaced every instance of
tree with f
why is why is that a fold operation
why isn't it some kind of tree apply or
something
the records is further down so this
empty list is the list of children
and because one doesn't have children it
gets an empty list
but if it had it would recourse further
this is called general functional
programming
sense and like tree has its own notion
of fold distinct from list
because it has a different algebraic
structure
so if if the tree was totally vertical
it would be the normal fault
basically
i understand this used to have a name
back in what was it
not beta what the hell was it called
that this had a name this operation
and it was
what is it called
back in 1980s style parallel programming
decided name
who knows i'm not at all convinced that
this should be called fold
i mean what's the analogous operation
for a graph for example
i don't think there is one i mean so so
something that we do in the physics
project lots
is uh blah blah blah
and then some thing which is a graph as
a list of rules effectively
that's this operation basically
right that's taking every um you know
for example
if you want to take a list of pairs and
turn that into a graph
let's say an undirected graph that would
be like
you know undirected edge triple at that
list of pairs
this is the analog of that operation i
think well so
graph doesn't have like a nested
structure
and that's what the fold is referring to
so like ordinary fold on a list
is interpret the the structure of the
list like it's a linked list
and then replace each link with a
function
boy i never thought about it that way i
guess you could think of it that way if
you wanted to
and that was the motivation for calling
this tree fold
it's a general concept for algebraic
data structures
i think we're sort of the victims
because i remember naming fold
and that wasn't the um
okay
it would be lovely if there was a better
name for this operation
um the fold is sometimes called reduce
yes indeed
ethan's complaining these meetings
aren't about machine learning i don't
think we've been live streaming
machine learning meetings we definitely
have been having them um
we'll we'll uh
time to livestream some more of those um
let's see
oh boy nick is sending something about
traversal of general data structures
yeah i mean this is this is like
i just did this big study of of uh
evaluation orders and traversal orders
for combinators
and yes it is a complicated subject and
it is much less obvious
unlike an iterator where it's pretty
obvious you have a one-dimensional
sequence
it's a lot less obvious what you do in
these general cases
um i mean in you know there's certainly
multiple traversal orders that might be
of interest
and here for instance it's completely
unobvious to me
in what order okay your claim is
that if you simply replace every tree
node by an
f there is a unique expression that
comes out
correct
i mean i mean if you wanna if you want
to say
traversal order like fold is a
always a post-order depth-first
traversal
no i'm saying that if what you're doing
is taking the whole symbolic expression
that is the tree
and replacing every node by an f
then you're right that there's a unique
such symbolic expression that
corresponds to
which is which is very much like a tree
expression
is it not yes so tree expression tree
rules
tree these are all special cases of tree
fold
tree fold generalizes all of them
yeah are we sure it's not
the right thing to just give tree
expression a second argument that's the
function
well it's a tree normally it will be
construct right the normal
the default function is construct if i'm
not mistaken no so the second argument
of tree expression
is this structure argument that we have
for expression tree where
there's like head trees heads
sub expressions arguments and you can
like give
custom rules oh boy
um
okay well let's see oh boy so i think
we are mixing three things here so
the use of a function f the order
and the extension between the three and
the and the data
yes
and and the first question was this last
one the distinction between
trees and data and how to find a
solution that could be generalizable to
any other function that will
need mapping functions in the future
right so so i just want to point out
that tree fold has an optional third
argument
that says it's a function that you apply
to a subtree
before you give it to the function f
and by default it's tree data
tree data which then gives the payload
yes
okay so this is just one model of of how
we might
solve this problem
okay so wait a minute what problem okay
okay let's go through again what
problems are we trying to solve
data versus subtrees yep
and how do we control that yep second
problem is how do you
in what form do you return this whole
collection of things
do you stuff it back in the tree or do
you collect it somewhere
i i don't think i don't think there's
like maps should return a tree
yeah i agree
the the constructing the tree into a
list of data
is a separate operation that has to be
done later
so but for example you could certainly
say scan
so reap the scan of you know scan or so
and that will give you in some traversal
order will give you
pieces of the tree right exactly
okay
so for example three cases would collect
things and give you a list of cases
like cases does
but map map should preserve structure
so another possibility we had considered
is having
a bit like group by that in which the
function to be applied
the f admits a rule notation it can say
f r o g and should you do something
first with g
i'm i'm not as thinking as clearly about
this as i should be and i'm also
uh supposed to be doing something else
here so
i think i think this will have to be is
is this blocking you guys in terms of
implementation or not
what do you think again i i just i would
say no
these are like nice to have functions
but
all right all right well let's let's
let's whoops
the echoing let's pick this up a
different time
um these are all good questions
again don't forget let's make sure we've
gone through every function in list
manipulation and so on
to make sure we know which of these are
plausibly supportable on trees
okay um
so we don't yeah so we know what what
we're dealing with
all right sounds good okay for those
following live streams i
i think i have another one in at uh
half past this hour about um
history of science and technology quite
different topic and then we have yet
another
one later on this afternoon another
design review
so uh thanks all
and thanks to folks on the live stream
and we hear you about the desire
to uh participate in some of our machine
learning meetings
and we'll see what we can do about that
all right thanks a lot guys